Gabriel: So good afternoon. I'm Gabriel Stricker,
Director of Communications
and Public Affairs here at Google and I'd
like to welcome all of you who are
here and who are tuning in to our latest Authors@Google
installment of "Behind
the Wheel of a Bookmobile." "Behind the Wheel
of a Bookmobile" is really, uh --
and if you can see it here is a quixotic journey
that was conceived by the
renaissance man Tom Corwin who purchased a
classic bookmobile, stocked it with
thousands of books, and is about to drive
it across the country, uh, along with
a series of notable authors including Dave
Eggers, Michael Pollan, Tom Robbins,
Amy Tan, Scott Turow, and many others. Tom
actually has two here with him
today, the acclaimed author Jane Ganahl and
author and Emmy-winning actor Peter
Coyote as well. And after today's talk Tom
is going to be interviewing some
people, uh, who will be giving him comments
about their reflections on books
and -- and bookmobiles and certainly if you
guys have any thoughts on that
you're welcome to talk to Tom and his crew.
But without further ado, let me
introduce and welcome back to the Googleplex
the author, producer, musician, and
dog whisperer, Tom Corwin.
[Applause]
Tom: Hello. Thanks for coming. So, umm, I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about
the evolution of this project and then, uh,
get Peter and Jane up and
hopefully maybe we can all participate in
a conversation. Umm, so I -- I would
say what one thing that I feel strongly about
in life is sort of following the
muse and it has led me some unusual places,
none more unusual than this. Umm,
but just as a matter of introduction I'm primarily
a musician and music producer
in this life and these are, uh, some of the
projects I've worked on and, uh, and
then at some point I actually wrote an e-mail
which beckoned to become a book --
something I had never considered doing before,
publishing a book -- umm, but it
sort of happened, I followed it, and that
turned into two books, "Mr. Fooster"
and, umm, "Mostly Bob" and, umm, and then
I was at dinner one night with a
friend of mine named Peter Laufer and he shared
this idea he had to, uh, extend
his personal library in his house which was
just overflowing by buying a
bookmobile and he sits down at dinner, he
has this ad with him and he says, you
know, I found it -- I had this idea and I
found this bookmobile for sale online
and, uh, I got all excited about it and then
found out that it was actually too
big to fit in my backyard. And I just got
-- I just sort of lit up and got all
excited about the bookmobile and by the end
of dinner had actually come up with
this concept of having authors drive it across
the country and interviewing readers
about the books that have touched their lives
and I became so possessed by it I
haven't stopped yet. I actually went to Gurnee,
Illinois, where this bookmobile
was actually in service until about eight
months ago and, uh, purchased this
bookmobile. And, umm, so then while we were
there, of course, the project
started. I -- it had to interview the bookmobile
librarians who had driven this
bookmobile for the last 18 years and hear
some of their stories and -- which are
really powerful and I found out not only is
the bookmobile itself, you know,
really important vehicle of enlightenment
and transformation but there's some
magic that happens between bookmobile librarians
and, uh, and the people who
patronize them. Like, they really feel a connection
to a sense -- and a sense
of purpose which is moving. Umm, this is Audrey,
who drove my bookmobile for 18
years and was pretty sentimental about its
leaving the premises. Umm, so then I
started calling and actually some authors
and the first author I called happened to
be,
uh, a friend of mine named Peter Coyote and
I said, Pete, I have this crazy
idea, you know, what do you think? And he
said, that is fabulous. Sign me up.
And, umm, so that was just this wonderful
confirmation and -- and I continued
making calls and then I -- my friend Jane
Ganahl, who founded Litquake, San
Francisco literary festival, sort of climbed
on, has been an amazing supporter,
has really helped with a lot of outreach which
has, you know, led to these --
this amazing list of authors who've signed
on to be part of it. So I, uh -- I
then proceeded to sort of do a launch event,
uh, at the American Library
Association convention and I brought a film
crew there and we invited people
onto the bookmobile and we did this christening.
Uh, what this photo misses is
the first swing of the champagne bottle which
just sorta clunked on the bumper
without breaking. A great moment. But -- and
so we shot for the day and it was
quite lovely and at the end of the day, uh,
the cameras are all put away and,
uh, this man walks up to me and says, you
know, I saw your bookmobile from the
floor of the convention. It looks just like
the one from my childhood. Would it
be okay if I stepped on? And I said, you know,
of course, and I motioned to the
camera man, this looks like this is an interview.
He said, you know,
everything's put away, it's out in the car.
>> I couldn't go to the public --
Tom: Excuse me. And so I pulled my, uh, flip
camera out of my pocket and
handed it to the camera man and he stands
behind me and, uh, Ralph Eubanks
begins to tell me how growing up in Mississippi
he was not allowed on the
bookmobile -- excuse me, was not allowed in
the library as a black man, as a
black child but he was allowed on the bookmobile.
>>
So I couldn't go to the public library in
my town but I could go to the
bookmobile and it was a white driver of -- white
driver and librarian as a pair
and they came to my house and it didn't matter
to them what color we were but we
could get books and we read. I still remember
getting "Across Five Aprils"
about the Civil War, I got "Johnny Tremain",
"Lad a Dog". We'd sit there and
kinda sit in the corner in the back and flip
through the books and my sister's
on the floor of the bookmobile deciding which
books we were going to get. And
if they didn't have something, we would -- they
would recommend books to us and
they'd say, well, we'll bring it the next
time we come. And I'd sit in the
backyard, under a big shade tree and read
those books. It absolutely shaped me
in a powerful way. It -- it showed me that
-- that reading could take you
places, you know, very far away. It was a
very remote rural place so I'm -- I
mean, I'd take these trips in these books.
Being a reader really helped me
become a writer and it was a bookmobile that
played a big role in it.
Tom: So, uh, the punch line is that Ralph
Eubanks not only grew up to be a
writer but he is currently the Director of
Publishing for the Library of
Congress. So it was really, uh, quite amazing,
the bookmobile's role in his
life. So, you know, the idea is to hit the
road and interview readers and
authors behind the wheel of the bookmobile.
So I picked up the bookmobile in
Chicago and drove it back to San Francisco
in October. I just wanna touch on a
few of those, uh, moments that happened along
the way. This is a good one.
[Laughing]
Tom: Umm, and then, you know, I always believed
that part of the -- the ark of
this story, which will have to prove itself
in the telling and -- or in the
making is that, you know, we're gonna -- there's
gonna be bumps along the way
and, umm, this is not one of them, actually.
This is actually a story of one of
the people I interviewed along the way, a
guy named Rob Goldhor, who had just
returned from Afghanistan and he spoke to
me about how a friend of his who was a
graduate student at Brown just sort of took
it upon themselves to collect books
from friends and send them to him at the base
and that he sort of inadvertently
became the base librarian, and, uh, and how
books really were this amazing, you
know, touch point to home and how powerful
that was. And I interviewed Rob on
the bookmobile and he was so eloquent about
the -- the importance of -- of
reading, you know, in the middle of a desert
and how that really became a thing
that kept him grounded and connected. And,
umm, that interview is on the web
site if you, uh, if you take a look at bookmobiletravels.com.
So now we get on
to the travails. I decided to -- I was thinking,
hey, yeah, we'll cross the
continental divide fresh outta Boulder and
I got about 35 minutes up the grade
and the bookmobile just completely overheated
and I was, uh, amused to find out
when I pulled over and opened the hood that
I was actually at Buffalo Bill's
grave site. So it made for a great -- great
shot at which point we had to
renegotiate -- re-navigate our route and,
uh, pick the lower country for the
route home. We hit blizzards and then we came
to the salt flats and I thought,
ah. I don't know if you've ever been to the
salt flats but I hadn't and they
are spectacularly beautiful and I was just
thinking and I thought how great it would
be to get
photographs of the bookmobile on the salt
flats. And I really -- I just
couldn't contain myself so I literally drove
up over the sidewalk and down into
the salt flats with the bookmobile and got
some pretty photos which was awesome
and some -- some great footage of the bookmobile
disappearing into the white
horizon. And then of course on the way out
the plot thickened and the
bookmobile sunk into the sand on the periphery
of the salt flats and, umm --
which turned into, uh, the most amazing scene
-- which you'll see in the movie.
Stay tuned -- where, you know, the first tow
truck comes and hitched up its
winch and when it turned on the winch instead
of the bookmobile coming to the
tow truck, the tow truck comes to the bookmobile.
Then they go home and come up
with the next machine and we end up with the
mud cat.
[Laughing]
Tom: And meanwhile there is, you know, great
characters who are showing up, uh,
the truck drivers who were stopping at the
rest stop were standing with their
arms crossed 'cause we were the best show
in town at the -- at that rest stop
and the, uh, tow truck driver and just wonderful
characters including this man
who ended up being our savior, uh, in orchestrating
sort of -- as an orchestra
conductor telling two tow trucks, me, and
my camera person what to do to sort of
finally angle us out of that shot -- that
spot. Umm, and, you know, everybody
we run into of course we -- we try to interview
and this guy was a wonderful
sort of soft spoken cowboy and. Umm, and so
I invited him on and he was looking
at books and I said, you know, can you tell
me, is there a book that you
remember from your childhood that was, you
know, especially powerful that's had
some meaning in your life? And he said, yep.
Still got it in the truck. And I
was like, yes, you know? So what -- what book
is that? He said, the Bible.
And, uh, I was just great. I mean, that's
true for of course a lot of people.
I mean, that's absolutely true what an amazing
book that is and -- and I said,
are there other books that you like to read?
And he goes, yep. I really like
Stephen King. So, umm, you know, he took a
Stephen King novel when he left and he
was just amazing and he was so generous and
so helpful and, you know, there had
been a lot of great characters along the way
and it's -- it's been really fun
already, you know, in the preliminary journey
to hear these personal stories and
how books have really been the catalyst for
change in people's lives and -- and
for staying connected to themselves and being
exposed to a world that's a lot
bigger than the one that they live in. So
that's the essence of "Behind the
Wheel of a Bookmobile" and, umm, now I'm gonna
invite, uh, Jane Ganahl, the
fabulous author and founder of Litquake, the
San Francisco literary festival, and
Peter Coyote up to the front of the room and
we're just gonna invite everybody really
to participate in a conversation about sort
of how storytelling and
literature is sort of in the -- inexorably
connected to community and these
things really are powerful anchor points.
So thank you.
[Applause]
Jane: I thought we could start -- can you
hear me -- but that's okay. I
thought we would start talking about storytelling
and how, umm, the one thing
that -- the common thread that seems to run
through all the aspects of
bookmobile was storytelling. We're filming
this for a documentary and we were
having authors come on board to tell their
stories to readers and we're asking
readers to tell their stories to authors.
And I guess my question is, why do
you think storytelling is still so important
and so relevant in 2010?
Tom: Uh, I think that, you know, stories are
really largely what connect us. I
mean, there's something very powerful about
story, umm, as a means for getting
insight into someone else's life in a nonintrusive
way and a story is powerful
and -- and has incredible depth and it's not
challenging to listen to a story.
And I think, you know, I'm -- one of the things
I'm especially excited about in
this project is really the readers' stories.
You know, I'm very interested in
the authors' stories of course as well but
I'm really interested in the human
story and how books and literature are our
catalyst for experience. And I
think, umm, you know, hearing from readers
and connecting authors and readers on
their common love of story has the power to
move us all in new directions.
Pete: I'll tell you a really short story.
A really well-known old Jewish actor
checks himself into an old-age home and the
first night he's there he dresses in
a tuxedo and he puts on his best shirt and
he decides to go down check the
action. He goes down in the lobby and he sees
a really elegant lady, late 70s
early 80s, and he sidles up to her and he
says, young lady, do you know who I
am? She looks him up and down, she says, ask
the desk clerk. He'll tell you.
>> Oh!
Pete: Perfect story; right? Sets up expectations,
sets a scene, you get a
character and then the rug's pulled out from
under you and you see the essential
ambivalence in a really simple situation.
I actually think that storytelling
is part of our DNA, that stories are part
of information transfer about what
human hardware is about and that the way we
make sense of the world is by
telling stories and communicating and there's
no culture on earth that doesn't
and the technology is not really adding anything
to the storytelling. It's
just changing the medium. So every movie,
every novel, every music video, every
successful song is just a -- a different mechanism
for basically transmitting
something about what it feels like to be alive
and I think that you can't be
human and not do that.
Jane: Umm, those of you who don't know Peter
Coyote very well wouldn't know
that -- I don't think it's working but whatever.
It's fine. Umm, he -- Pete
was a very act -- is a very active on the
political side, too, and I think
there's a correlation sort of talking about
our own personal experiences via
Twitter, today I had a really good day versus
what he does which is forward
frequently, almost close to a daily basis
from time to time, things that he
finds interesting about the world and stories
that you should know about and,
uh, to me that's sort of a different kind
of storytelling. It's like, this is
what I think you should know about because
this is important to me in my -- in
my universe. So I guess that's the digital
version of -- of storytelling and,
uh, and high-tech --
Pete: And it has a shadow and we gotta talk
about the shadow. Umm, the -- a
virtual community doesn't bring you soup when
you're sick and a virtual
community doesn't bury you when you die and
one of the things I've actually just
stopped about a month ago I went to a long
-- week-long zen retreat and one of
the things I resolved to do was to stop forwarding
all my e-mails because I was
not doing the essential work that I can really
do which was finish a political
book. I was sending everybody else's literature
around. And one of the
reasons that I wrote this book is I wrote
it for my son's generation who's about
25 now and I was comparing and contrasting
the last three months of Lyndon
Johnson's term as President with the last
three months of George Bush's term as
President and Lyndon Johnson was rendered
completely impotent. He could not do
anything and George Bush was making mischief,
according to my definition, up to
his very last day in office and the big difference
was that there was no
generation of young people out in the streets.
We were blogging, we were
Googling, we were writing our opinions, and
that that had somehow taken on the
space that collective action used to take
and somehow the shadow side, to me, of
the computer is that we're not out in the
streets and we're not basically
saying, this is an unacceptable narrative
of the United States. This is not the
story we signed on for and we're not gonna
tell it and we're not gonna tolerate
it. I just wanted to really say that at Google.
>> [Laughing]
Jane: That's not exactly like biting the hand
of the people who gave us these
burritos but --
Pete: But it's all of us. I use computers,
too.
Jane: Right.
Pete: I mean, Google didn't invent this problem
but it is a cultural problem
that we've fragmented community and we're
all in our houses or we're all at our
computers and we're not shoulder-to-shoulder
out in the streets anymore.
Jane: Absolutely. Umm, speaking of high-technology,
maybe you could speak a
little, Tom, to -- I know you can already
see that the shelves are stocked with
books. You're also talking about maybe doing
some kind of technology set-up inside so that
when you go from town to town that people
could actually read books online or
what are you still thinking of for that?
Tom: Well, umm, I just love the idea of this
wonderful analog vehicle, you
know, telling a story about literature, you
know, as it exists in contemporary
times which absolutely includes digital publishing.
And, umm, so I'm interested
in including digital publishing, representing
it as well, on the bookmobile and
additionally, you know, of course we'll be
posting as we go, and blogging, and posting
the most poignant moments in short clips on
the web site so people can follow
along and, uh, and the stories, you know,
live, you know, in the immediate
moment as we travel across the country.
Jane: And why take back roads? I mean, is
it -- is it as simple as we don't
wanna get stuck on the freeways driving or
is there something about going through
back roads communities that have their own
culture and their own voices and
connecting with authors in these small towns?
I mean, what -- why did you make
that choice?
Tom: I mean, I think that, you know, it -- it's
the best opportunity for good
storytelling and I think that there's, you
know, there's more individuation and
there's more small communities that have voice,
and story and identity that, you
know, we can touch into by taking a back roads
route that will be different than
if we take an interstate and stop in major
cities along the way. Umm, it's just
not as diverse a journey across America and
really not really necessarily as
representative of the diversity of culture
that exists in the United States.
Jane: And I know your hope is to take some
authors along with you but also to
connect with authors along the way.
Tom: Yeah. Absolutely. I mean, umm, right
now, our author list is very Bay
Area-centric. There definitely are also other
authors along the way but because my
community is the Bay Area that was where I
started making calls. Umm, and some
of those interviews will happen in the Bay
Area and others will fly in but a
very important part of the journey is -- is
the regional stories and so we
definitely will be, uh, picking up authors
regionally as we pass through their
areas and inviting 'em on the bookmobile to
drive a segment and tell -- talk to
us about books and their -- the place they
live and how those things intercept.
Jane: What has surprised me as I have contacted
some of these authors myself
is, umm, many -- as you say, many of them
are urban, you know, San Francisco Bay
Area people and, uh, you know, you talk to
somebody like Andrew Sean Greer,
whose book, "Max Tivoli", was, like, the No.
1 choice of book clubs in 2006 or
something. Huge literary guy. His first question
was, well, I'll go if I can
drive the bookmobile and they all have this
crazy thing for bookmobiles and
there's a wonderful, wonderful video of Daniel
Handler, AKA Lemony Snicket,
on the web site where he talks about the importance
of bookmobiles and how
he -- he literally became a writer because
of libraries and bookmobiles. So,
umm -- and on that -- I did have a question
in there. Umm, why famous authors?
Is it -- is it partly to kind of draw attention
to the project but also because
I think -- is it -- is it because people find
it really interesting to hear
authors who have made it talk about how they
made it and -- and what books meant
to them?
Tom: You know, I think to me that -- that
choice is about -- it's a lot about
bringing eyes to the subject and it's also
-- it's -- as much I am interested in
talking to those authors about their books
I'm much more interested, and I think
the, you know, people who will be interested
in paying -- watching will be
interested in knowing who's inspired these
people. I mean, who -- what authors,
what reading, what life experiences have inspired
them to do what they do and
maybe, you know, influenced their lives in
meaningful ways or changed their
personal mythology? And, umm, I think those
personal stories it's just, it's a
way of connecting people with something really
important through people they're
interested in. And also I feel like there's
a power in connecting authors and
the readers in their common love of books.
I'm -- I'm really, uh, you know, not
looking to create a celebrity platform as
much as create an opportunity for the
readers and the authors to connect and I think
that that's part of what authors
are drawn to about the project. You know,
it's sort of down -- it's walking the
street. It's really talking to your readers
and connecting in a meaningful way
instead of, uh, when you do an author event
I think there's not as much
opportunity to connect in a -- on a mutual
level, you know, across the table.
Jane: Umm, as the director of the Litquake
festival every year we have some
kind of, uh -- and it's ten years old now
-- every year we've had some kind of
event around memoirs and it's always packed
and there is something very,
very compelling that people just are really
drawn to memoirs and because it's
the ultimate imprint sharing of your experience
and Pete and I have both written
one and, uh, I found it harrowing and rewarding
team, uh, maybe Pete can talk
about why he felt compelled to put his life
-- tell his own story in print form.
Pete: Well, one of the things I did with my
book was make the decision not to
make it about my life but to make it about
a decade, to make it, uh, about the
people that I shared it with. Umm, it's hard
to sit out and say I'm of such
stellar importance that you should sit down
and read 385 pages about me. I know
Jane didn't do that either. So the truth of
it is that the dividing lines between
self and everything around you are semi permeable
and I wanted to write about the
60s because after Reagan became President,
umm, a kind of collective decision
was made that, uh, one generation of active,
engaged students was enough and
there was a conscious decision made to define
the 60s as a failure and they sent
all that youthful energy into the stock market.
And, umm, I wanted to tell the
story for my children, umm, in my words so
that it wasn?t misdefined and I wanted
them to know something about some of the luminous
beings that I ran around with
and how seriously people dedicated themselves
to change for, you know, change
that was not gonna make them rich or famous
but that was gonna make life, umm,
perhaps gentler or easier or fairer or -- for
a lot of other people. So there
was nothing to do but write the book.
Jane: [Laughing]
That's funny. I've never heard anybody say
that. I just
had to do it or nothing else to do but write
it and it's a fabulous book, too.
Peter Coyote's a hell of a writer. What about
giving away books, Tom? What's
that all about? Are you going to ask people
to swap your favorite books or just
hand them book and ask them to talk about
their favorite book? Are you
bribing them with something?
Tom: No, Jane.
Jane: [Laughing]
Tom: The idea is that we're giving away books
-- we're not just giving away
books, giving away a book in exchange for
an interview so that there's an
exchange so that people when we pull into
a town and we open the doors of the
bookmobile and we invite people on, if they
are inclined to share a story, they
can take a book, any book they like from the
bookmobile. And I just feel like
there's something, uh, there's -- there's
something very nice in the exchange,
in the idea of exchange. Umm, you give me
a story, I give you a book and I just
feel like there's -- there's just some -- some
inherent poetry in that and it
also is nice to be exchanging with people
and be able to give something away and
to see what they take and -- and hopefully
provide a launching point for
something new, some new perspective for them,
you know, ideally. I'm hoping
that people will take books that are a challenge
for them or something they
haven't experienced before.
Jane: Uh, I will say that, you know, early
in this campaign, if you will call
it that, when I was sort of new and hearing
about what Tom was doing and he went
to Chicago to get the bookmobile and, umm,
it's not that I had my doubts that
this was a good idea. I always thought it
was a fantastic idea but it wasn't
until he e-mailed me and said, you have to
see this video of Ralph Eubanks that
I got today. Then I watched it and I just
-- oh, I actually cried. In fact I
cried again watching it this time and I thought,
this is why this project is so
beautiful and this is -- this is why it has
to -- has to happen.
Pete: And Ralph Eubanks and I both mentioned
the same book on the ride down
here.
Jane: Which book?
Pete: "Lad the Dog".
Jane: "Lad a Dog".
Pete: I said, "Lad of Sunnybrook Farm" which
was another one in the series but
it's funny how you remember those early books.
Jane: Yeah. And there's -- if you haven't
been on the web site I encourage you
to go on it to see the others -- the young
man, Rob Goldhor, who served in
Afghanistan talked about how Doug Peacock's
"Walking It Off", which was fairly
well-known book about the Vietnam era, once
he got back from Afghanistan and
lifted him up because he was -- you know,
it was a pretty difficult situation
and how that saved him -- I mean, every single
-- there aren't too many videos
up now but every single one that is a glowing
reason for doing this project
and why we're all so excited to get it start
-- get it going. Umm, documentary.
You're -- one thing that gets a little bit
lost in all this is that you're
filming everything for an eventually doc -- an
eventual documentary and what do
you hope to do with that?
Tom: Well, umm, you know, I hope to screen
it in theaters and I also think that
it has, you know, a lot of potential longer
life in film screening programs in
the libraries across the United States and
there are a lot of -- there's, you
know, a lot of targeted audiences interested
in these stories. So, umm, exactly
how it will be marketed, you know, I can't
say exactly at this point since it's
a long process and we're at the beginning
of it but certainly -- and I also
think at this time in terms of distribution
and movies and the reality of it,
umm, theatrical life is not the main venue
for -- for documentaries anymore.
And, uh, and certainly, you know, there's
a -- there's the television venue and
also there's, you know, relevant institutions
like libraries for instance for
this film that would be, you know, would be
great screening opportunities.
Jane: And how do you plan to keep getting
your books re-stocked? I mean --
Tom: That -- that hasn't seemed to be a challenge.
Friends of the Library
organizations have offered to donate books
and they exist across the United
States, publishers are very, uh, generous
with books and libraries have been
incredibly generous and anxious to contribute.
So, umm, and there's also an
organization called "First Book" which is
a great nonprofit that, uh -- with a
literacy outreach mission that has, uh, central
depositories of books that they
collect from publishers 'cause they identified
that one of the key contributions
to illiteracy in this country is actually
just access to books. It's hard to
imagine that when you live in a city but I
guess in rural areas it's just, you
know, access to books is really an issue.
So, umm, they collect books from
publishers and they distribute them through
nonprofits across the United States.
So they have offered, also to replenish to
bookmobile as we cross the country.
Jane: Sounds like that's not gonna be a problem
for you. Perhaps gas will be
more of a problem than books.
Pete: Well, he'll just watch his diet.
[Laughing]
Jane: Eat burritos every day. Uh, maybe I
wanna talk just a little bit more
about books and how they can make bridges
between people that ordinarily
wouldn't have anything in common with each
other. I was sort of touched by your
conversing with the cowboy, I forgot what
you said his name was, and the book that changed
his life was "the Bible" and, uh, and he also
likes Stephen King and yet,
uh, you know, the -- the communion between
you two was very probable. I mean,
probably his life could not be any more different
than yours but, uh, I think
that's part of the beauty of book -- book
lovers that sort of can bond over.
Tom: Honestly, I mean, that's one of the things
I am most excited about
relative to this project is the opportunity
to connect people who wouldn't
otherwise necessarily be exposed to each other.
'Cause I think at the heart of
these stories, umm, some of the stories that
we've collected already and a lot
of the stories that we're certain to collect
is a point of connection, you know,
and there are -- I mean, even in communities
that have a high degree of literacy,
I mean, there are -- there are stories relative
to books and reading that I
think will touch us all, will touch the most
literate of us and to create an
opportunity for us to witness each other around
this topic that we're all
curious about, books and literature is -- is
to me the most exciting aspect of
the project.
Pete: I have, uh, 56 cartons of books and
they're in cartons right now because
I built a little office for myself outside
of my house and I gave my wife my
office and she tore down my floor-to-ceiling
bookshelves and I hadn't anticipated
that part. So I've got all these books in
cardboard boxes -- numbered boxes.
And there's another aspect of books that people
don't really talk about which is
your book collection is a kind of way of understanding
your own mind and seeing
it organized. So when you're sitting in a
room and the walls are lined with
books and your eyes fall on -- this is gonna
sound terribly like pandering but
it's not -- the title is like a little Google
search. So you see these single
sentences and each time you -- you get the
title, you're reminded of the subject
matter and you're reminded of all the stuff
you got about it and the meeting of
the author's mind and it's there and books
are an artifact. They're not
electronic. You can pick it up, you can take
it with you, you can fold it stick
it in your back pocket, take it with you to
the john. It's a very, very, very
sophisticated medium and we tend to think
of it as primitive but in terms of
diversity it's actually kinda better than
my Google. The batteries don't wear
out, you know, I don't need radio reception.
It's like -- so there is --
there's just this tried and true and simplified
technology that the world has
taken to its bosom and that we've somehow
created identities in relationship to
and I know that I walk around in my house
feeling sort of like half a person
because my books are not on the wall.
Tom: You know, that just makes me think about
this other point that I think is
interesting and it's also perhaps part of
the inspiration for this project which
is, you know, I am sort of a tech guy. I mean,
I love technology but I am
concerned about the impact our technological
society is having on us. I'm
concerned, uh, that we don't have as much
time in our own heads without the
distraction of something electronic around
us, I'm concerned about the loss of
introspection which I think is really a tangible
loss. And I love technology
but I can tell you personally I'm very aware
I have much less time in my own
head with my -- with my own thoughts. And,
umm, and I hope that the bookmobile
and these stories can, uh, you know, will
inspire people and remind people to --
to connect to these points. I mean, books
are -- one of the wonderful things
about them is they are points of reflection
and they are opportunities for
introspection and relation -- relating to
our own thoughts in reflection to
someone else's thoughts. And, umm, you know,
I think that it's a really
unexamined territory, what this price is that
we're paying for our love of
technology.
Jane: Are there any questions? Does anybody
have any questions for -- for Tom,
or Pete, or me? Otherwise we'll just keep
yakking up here. Do you have a
question? Sure.
>> [Pause]
Jane: And by the way --
Pete: The shortest distance between two-points.
>> [Laughing]
>> So as we have these expert story tellers
on stage and it's a subject that
came up a little earlier, this is probably
a very simple and basic question but
I thought a lot about, you know, what makes
a good story teller because
obviously everyone wants to share their experiences
and some people are a little
better at it than others. Umm, what -- what
is it in the people you've talked
to so far in your professional experiences
of the people you know, what are the
qualities that make someone a good story teller?
'Cause some folks could take
the most incredible instance and turn it into
something quite boring whereas
other people can turn the story of two folks
at a -- in a -- in an old folks'
home and make it sound interesting. Thanks.
Tom: I think Pete's gonna have the best answer
to that question somehow. But,
you know, to me, honesty is a great quality
of good storytelling and for me,
when I feel that there's something genuine
happening and it's not wandering too
far away from its essence, then that's incredibly
captivating. Pete?
Pete: I completely agree that I think the
first engaging thing is authenticity.
But then, within that, umm, I think details.
You know, kind of -- some people
have a sense for what detail is going to spring.
Like the story that I told
you. It really makes a difference to know
that the guy dressed up in a tuxedo,
and he had a hat and he had a bow tie because
you get a visual impression of his
grandiosity and so then he's coming in like
this high-status guy and so when the
woman scans him up and down she trumps his
status and you get that through the
details. So I think that -- that good writing
is always concrete -- good story telling is
always concrete and you don't overload people
with details. Some
people have an instinctive sense of what detail
is required to sell the story
and what isn't. So between authenticity and
details.
Pete: Yeah.
Jane: Well, I just -- I guess we're wrapping
up here so I wanna thank
Google for having us. In fact, Tom.
Tom: Thank Google.
Pete: Thank you, Google.
Tom: Umm, it's a pleasure to be here. It's
fun to be up here with Jane and
Pete, two of my very favorite people and,
umm, I wanna say -- I guess now
we're gonna have -- some people are gonna
come take a tour on the bookmobile
which is parked outside. Also just to let
people know that, uh, the web site
for the project is bookmobiletravels.com and
we are fund raising and, uh, it
looks like we're maybe a third towards our
budget but we welcome any ideas or
contributions about, uh, you know, fund raising
and contributions to the fund
raising. There is a way to contribute on the
site. It is a non profit. And,
umm, thanks to Google, thanks to Ann, thanks
to Gabe. Pleasure.
Pete: I have a question. Since Google is both
a noun and a verb, you know,
Google is a place and it's also a verb, is
one ever Googled?
Pete: Can you say "I've been Googled"? You
can? Okay. Will I know it?
[Laughing]
Pete: Oh, that's right. Oh, good. See --
Gabriel: Thank you so much.
Pete: Thanks.
[Applause]